right I'm Terry deacon
I began in colleges in physics like many
here probably gave it up quicker than
most became very interested in the time
in the excitement about cybernetic
theory which was going on in the late
70s and information theory in fact my
first book was a 900-page co-authored
book on the Apple 2 computer and its
design absurd sort of sidetrack I took
it early on why-flyers
got my degree but in the late 70s I
picked up by virtue of some crazy guy in
a bookstore he says you have to read
because I was reading all this you know
cybernetics and brains and computers and
stuff he said you have to you have to
read this philosopher Charles purse I
thought he was crazy because I didn't
didn't think philosophy was worth my
time
and eventually just to please this crazy
guy in the bookstore I picked up a copy
of it and started reading it and I got
so disturbed that I basically dropped
out of school for a year spent my little
bit of money to buy the
volumes that were then available you
know this is totally out of order both
volumes of his work and struggled
through it trying to make sense of it
got my undergraduate degree writing a
thesis about this and then said okay I'm
gonna go where the papers are Charles
purses papers are buried in the library
in the Houghton library in Harvard and I
got in remarkably you know they liked
the paper I wrote I guess and I was
going to go on and do this philosophy
stuff but this is when Hillery was there
Klein I went to work with a guy named
Israel Schaeffler nobody was interested
in it it was the most disappointing
experience I had now it turns out that
purses become a big topic since then but
at the time nobody was interested and I
was I was just crushed and I went to MIT
hung out with people like Chomsky and
photo and got even more angry and I met
a guy there who was a close to
retirement a neuroscientist who had
discovered some of the first tracer
techniques or look
connections in the nervous system now
I've been studying their nervous system
you know papers and books as you know as
a side issue and I was younger and Sur
took me on and sweet old guy from his
name was Bali Nauta and we began to I
began to get more and more involved in
the neurosciences and eventually sort of
jumped ship into a new program in in
biological anthropology but my real
interest was to do neuroscience in an
evolutionary way I use this new tool to
do sort of evolutionary neuroscience by
comparing the circuitry in different
brains and I began my career in that
direction to sort of you know leaning to
this other dark side and spend a lot of
time doing tracing studies and monkeys
and rats and cats and things like that
through the 90s trying to sort of get a
sense of how nervous systems and changed
by the late 90s I left Harvard and got a
position Harvard Medical School in
Boston University and began using a new
technique that I thought would tell us
more about the evolution which is
cross-species transplantation but you
can take neurons from embryonic brains
from one species and stick it in another
brain and say okay now what's it doing
and one of the nice things about that is
that the the proteins are all different
there they're effectively the same but
they're different enough that you can
use an antibody to look at them and so
we were able to watch in effect
literally watch axons find their targets
in different rains and so i've most of
the work that i did was using pig
fetuses into rats and monkeys and
eventually it turns out in humans and it
was wonderful we could watch this
connections being made and you know you
if you want to study the quote
computation of the brain you need to
know what's connected to what and so it
seemed to me yes yes I didn't do it I
was not allowed of course but we had
developed this technique that we had
shown worked in rats and monkeys and and
we had shown that in the rats it
actually we gave them Parkinson's
disease basically what this is from the
the frozen addicts story we learned that
there is
you know a drug that you could give to
rats or monkeys and they would become
parkinsonian and then the question was
could we cure it you know could we stick
neurons in these brains and in fact yes
we could it was remarkable and so
eventually cut the company Genzyme but
bought the patent so to speak
we got nothing except we get to do our
experiments you know the usual thing
they I think they sold it for huge
amounts of money
and they they actually transplanted 12
12 individuals as quote safety trials
the sad news is that by the time they
were doing this I knew that all the
grafts were going to be rejected but I
had signed a nondisclosure agreement and
all this stuff and it went ahead there
were actually two real successes in that
for a very short period of time
eventually everybody rejected their
grafts or they died these were mostly
fairly old people
we had one man actually the very first
one we transplanted interestingly enough
he was Jewish and he had to go to his
rabbi to discuss the question as to
whether having pig cells in his brain
would somehow violate and and the rabbi
being the the sensible man said well you
didn't eat it did you it's okay I don't
see anything you know in the scripture
said you can't do this and so he went to
and he was actually the most successful
case he was frozen literally for the
last couple of years of his life had
been basically spending his time in a
bed or a chair and he actually during
the first six to eight months afterwards
began to get up and get around he tried
to practice golf again he painted his
front porch and put up a gate and stuff
like that eventually didn't make it but
it was remarkable learnings that we
found and the reason that we were able
to do this is that it became clearer and
clearer that no matter where we put the
appropriate cells we know what kind of
cells they were from where you take it
in the brain wherever we put it the
axons found appropriate targets or what
we might call homologous targets and and
they would do so if we put them in the
wrong place and what that was telling us
is that across species that are as
different as as pigs and rats and
monkeys and humans that
the same you might call guidance
molecules were available and so it
raised an interesting question the
question I had been pursuing having to
do with but molecular biologists had not
gone this far by the 1990s but we have
begun to find a lot of really conserved
features but certainly for all over the
cerebral cortex we didn't know and we
still don't know exactly what guides
these axons to particular specific
targets but anyway we were able to find
that we actually could see that not only
they found their targets but we could
actually see that the synapses were
functioning and so on
and by e/m so there's a remarkable
finding but it basically said that
what's different about human brains is
not that and in part of my work in
anthropology and neuroscience was to try
to get the questions what's different
about human brains compared to other
brains and how is that the brains evolve
that's sort of what drove my work all
through the 90s I left that work in
about 2000 and transplanted myself out
to the west coast of Berkeley and it
just it was just after this what I felt
was a debacle in which I had signed a
nondisclosure agreement and I knew that
all these both safety trials were not
going to help the people who thought
they're you know like everybody else
who's like this they expect they're
going to maybe be the lucky one
and so I basically sort of backed away
from that work and just went back to
comparative work but it also let me gave
me a chance to go back to earlier
questions and these are questions that
that sort of purse and his philosophy
brought up for me and in the study of
brain evolution and how brains change
this question about the emergence of new
structure and new function human
language of course being one of these
classic examples of something that just
doesn't seem to have any nice neat
correlates early on in other species
using totally different parts of the
brain to communicate than other species
do it really caught my attention but it
wasn't it isn't it what we call an
emergence question now what's
interesting is that and this is where it
fits in with this group
because of my work in human evolution
human origins and cognition in a sort of
indirect way I became invited again and
again to various quasi religious groups
I became someone that the the Townsend
not so much towns in the Templeton group
kept calling to come to these various
meetings and and I would and in fact one
of the very first ones I came to we were
all talking about what we did and I and
I basically said well no I you know I'm
not an atheist I'm an anti theist
and it got everybody very upset and we
had great conversations and it turns out
that what I learned is that there's a
huge interest in quote emergentism and
people like peacock and others that many
of you may know about sort of try to
promote this idea was that sort of God
of the gaps for some people but it was
also maybe a way out for those who were
looking for a sort of compatibilism and
so I've been again and again invited to
these groups and I had been asked to
publish papers in many of their books
and that sort of thing and so it's been
a wonderful dialogue I find that there
is an interest in this question that
we're about to struggle with that's in
even not the the fundamental Fiat
theology but in people at self for
example I just got an award from a
Unitarian group called the Institute for
religion in the age of science and they
gave me a reward for this current book I
just produced and because they're
interested in these questions these are
these are not the sort of hardliners but
the people are sort of you know almost
secularists it so it's a very
interesting issue so let me just say
that a couple of things about what I'm
interested in what I could change my
mind about first of all right now I'm
very much interested in rethinking the
very concept of information I think we
have a remarkably powerful physical and
logical theory of information that dates
from Claude Shannon of course but of
course it has nothing to say about
reference has nothing to say about
anything normative
when you provide information to me
there's a normative feature there and in
biology our understanding of information
both has reference and normativity so
that the Shannon model is not good
enough and so I've been struggling to
make sense of this idea in evolutionary
biology and and I think it's really a
crucial question and for the origins of
life people and what what is you know
how is it that a molecule becomes about
something that's a really interesting
question we assume that that's true in
hindsight and we look back but it's not
okay thank you uh you philosophers I'll
let you think whatever you want but so
that's been really interesting to me and
I've been struggling with a way to think
that through and to become formal about
it to really make it clear what I think
that relationship is because I think it
can be has to be something that we can
make sense of so in this respect there's
a there's a couple of things that I
first of all think to be the case and
but I'm willing to be convinced up
number one I don't think brains are like
computers I've spent a lot of time with
brains and they're and they just don't
look like computing devices to me and
and yet I'm not saying that it's not a
functionalist physical kind of story I
just don't think our understanding of
computation is big enough to accomplish
what we want to say about this and I'm
really interested in how to expand that
notion because I give all the meaning to
my computer my computers like like like
a car engine
but I've assigned various values to the
what it's doing and so on and if I'm a
computer to then who's assigning it you
know this you get the you get the same
problem sort of running back and back
and back now number of people say oh no
it's just because we're now situated in
the world what my computer situated in
the world and certainly one that runs an
arm in a factory is situated in the
world I don't find any reason to think
there's somebody home there I think
there is something more that we have to
deal with I'm willing to be convinced
that now I'm just a computer and all
this stuff is just running probe
that's one thing I'm willing to be
convinced of just but I but I need to
have good science that tells me how to
think that through the second one and
I'm glad to be in a room with a bunch of
physicists is that I don't think that
understanding mind consciousness or how
brains work requires us to do quantum
theory a whole lot of people as as you
probably know you think that somehow
consciousness requires us to understand
entanglement and things like that I'm
glad to hear that but you know I'm
willing to I'm willing to be convinced
that that you need to know quantum
theory to understand how brains work but
I don't think so myself
I think I think you're right that the
tools certainly could be relevant but
but to understand some of these rather
strange features that we don't really
have an explanation for we have great
description of to understand why I have
this experience it seems to me to be
something that I've never felt I needed
to do now I you know some I'm not a
quantum physicist so maybe I missed
something but that's that's sort of one
of my questions
you